greetings from podcast Ville we ain't
[ __ ] around it's Wednesday the 15th
of April and guess what you got another
month in seclusion [ __ ] so get
ready anyway listen you're online and I
want to talk to you about something the
church is brought to you by expressvpn
expressvpn is great for protecting your
privacy and security online especially
now since you're online constantly but
now that you're stuck at home you can
also use it to unlock foreign movies and
TV shows that are only available in
other countries ah you can binge watch
Doctor Who on UK Netflix or if you're
into Japanese anime you could watch
spirited away from on Netflix in Japan
it's easy to use even for a dummy like
me just open the app change the location
and that's it you could choose from 100
different countries so do me a favor
right now the church family can go to
Express VPN calm slash Church to get
ready for this one I'm gonna give you
three months for free most and three
months for free just because I love you
the [ __ ] debt and I don't want you
getting tampered with on your [ __ ]
computer next thing you know your credit
card is being used in Russia
goodbye Kirby but no way so support the
podcast watch what you want and protect
yourself and expressvpn calm again the
family gets three months free when you
go to express VPN dot-com slash Church
check this [ __ ] melee oh [ __ ]
Wednesday morning [ __ ] excuse and
the situation is the same
welcome to church
the Wednesday by the problem
[Music]
and staying again that's what you're
gonna do
listen to the church stay in mind your
[ __ ] business I got my main man
the original Catholic mr. Steve Simone
the only cabby to go to church this
Sunday
yeah i streamed it then you're good for
you god bless you you know you don't
need to go down there I got it
I started getting pissed off because
people like what is rednecks doing it
well I'm driving my car that's it
outside of church what's that gonna do
for you you got you get you get more
magical powers sitting outside the strip
club maybe you'll find a power on the
floor something like that what the [ __ ]
is wrong with people
first of all church is something that
you go to every day it's in your heart
mm-hmm you know nothing bothered me more
when I was a kid in 73 they were telling
you that there was two mortal sins not
going to church and murder and I'm like
how does that even on the same so how
can I not go to church but if I murder
somebody I'm like [ __ ] you yeah then I
started going to church and I started
seeing people I started seeing people
from the church and how they feel in
real life and they think because they go
to church that makes them a good
Catholic Christian unorthodox or a
synagogue Jew whatever the [ __ ] they are
like anybody who goes to church I get it
I get that it makes you feel better it's
about trying to get that sense of Jesus
it's a part of trying to get that sense
of peace well 50% of people will go to
church so they go for a social activity
to be seen and I can tell I smell that
[ __ ] right the funny yeah I think one of
the things that made an impression on me
and I don't know if this taken for
whatever it is and I'll paraphrase it
but somebody once told me that a church
isn't it's not like an art museum for
perfect people it's not you're not a
perfect piece of art that's going there
to be showing off but it's more like a
hospital for sick people so when you see
people showing up at church and then you
see them acting like an animal seven and
six and a half days a week it's not
necessarily that they're phony but at
least they're making that step to try to
change their life and I'm of that point
of view where I don't judge anybody you
know I don't I don't know what's in
anybody's heart and it's not going to
church one day a week I'd rather be a
gentleman seven days a week that's it
yeah I took that from you where you make
somebody's everybody so yeah I've seen
the Mexican lawn mower down there yeah i
sat there watching watching him and he
had a bandana around his face and I said
this is what you doing started going to
church over the house I got the cold
this wall in the refrigerator and I put
a [ __ ] a mask that's exactly just
walked down the corner I gave him the
[ __ ] water and the wood and he put
the mask on yeah take a picture I didn't
put it on [ __ ] exactly go for people see
me be in it but how good did you feel
after that I felt like a million bucks
exactly the chick next door to me needed
a couple mass he's got a little girl
yeah a girl place of my little girl yeah
you know this lady one day knocked on my
door so that are you hungry
like I never met the lady before oh yeah
no I said I like all they know each
other okay
she turned me on to beef stroganoff oh
yeah Granville never what that I know
name know what everybody goes do you
want
we stroganoff I think they gave me to my
mistake I didn't have to pay for me and
my wife is like sure do you know that
now we go to Grandma once a month they
get the beef stroganoff it's delicious
Wow
I don't eat it then I take it to go
because they so carry dishes so I don't
go there I can't lie to you but I get it
I pick it up my wife and me pick it up
yeah but that's our last way he is you
know so these are racks like right now
I'm really looking for you Mary to come
out wait Tim you you see what's going on
demand so well [ __ ] [ __ ] under the
thing till May 15th
and Dana White has that one I have a
fine on the 16th
Wow you know who it's like here's a guy
that never ends I know he's got people
on top and only giving him back hands if
you know the whole story
yeah there's people that he has to
answer to don't think that but they're
making them that crazy because they want
that money
mmm you know everybody wants to that's
why this fight had a happen on the 18th
there was a payment that was do
something was going on and so now he
wants to have well on the 16th you know
I see all these people doing shitty
things to people now I saw Ticketmaster
do something today yeah they're not
getting refunds anymore e4y yeah so what
you're just gonna hold on to your money
yeah what you need to do from a time
when what I yeah I don't know what date
you go back to you should out on my
client to find it when I told everybody
to get that money back bleep did I not
yeah but is this started right when I
cigars I go do me a favor guys go get
your money back right now don't hesitate
don't wait don't play games go get your
money this is not gonna be good I told
you guys I don't want them to have your
money right okay I don't want them to
have your money if there's no date in
the air and right now there's no dates
in the air okay so nobody should have
your [ __ ] money yeah
Miami told me that said in the back it's
gonna take 10 to 14 days I don't know
what think I'm doing Cleveland and uh
well the other place I'm going to the
other Indianapolis
you know I got a date in Vegas who knows
what's gonna happen now I'm normally
given addendum yeah
with saying listen we can't put sixteen
hundred people in here all right don't
look at 480 do you mind taking up eight
but no you know you guys were always
good to me you know I get it yeah
I understand what's going on you know so
uh but let's who gives a [ __ ] about that
you have made me so proud the last three
weeks
ah every day I wake up to see what
urinary that's how I've been keeping
myself happy
I'm just making delicious me wait cuz
I've been also working out I've been
doing what you said I'm getting out in
the Sun I'm doing my push-ups I'm trying
to do the intermittent fasting I'm
trying to go at least fifteen hours a
day without eating but when I do eat I
kill it
I'm making all my favorite food from
scratch and I'm glad over the last
twenty years I couldn't find the food
that I love so I had to learn how to
make it myself so now I'm in lockdown
I'm loving it I'm your pork sandwich is
one of the best in the business and I
grew up in Edgewater not very good
Edgewater had a [ __ ] pork sandwich
H&B restaurant
mm-hmm that you would kill for four
greatest pickles and hot sauce uh with a
piece of provolone cheese you have no
[ __ ] idea yeah
pork brain you come in a strong second
that's nothing that God dude is dead you
know dad you're the new [ __ ] reigning
champion right there I mean you've
always enjoyed cooking this is what I
told people in the beginning of this
thing when it started that you can look
at this two ways yes this is very bad
yes we're gonna suffer financially and
yes we're not gonna have a lot of the
things that we want to do so start
something new
absolutely and you have impressed the
[ __ ] out of me from the pizzas I know
the first PT made I called you you were
very honest I don't know yeah it was
tricky but you just kept making that's
it random sample them if they weren't
good you brought into one of the kids
who's dying this will push you over the
top the pizza I made yesterday was the
best pizza ever
it looked [ __ ] good like it look like
he really got it what type of oven do
you have to eat home oven see that's
what I like about the videos I put out
because when I was trying to learn this
stuff everybody wants to show you how to
do this under perfect situation with the
thousand two thousand dollar pizza oven
with all the best tools I don't have all
any of that but I learned how to make it
in a normal person kitchen I have my
cheat codes and I encourage everybody to
do it because it gives you a sense of
accomplishment to like you feel good you
like I made this it gives you something
to do with your time it was the gnocchi
homemade for made a scratch from scratch
is this some of your mother taught you
know rocky has always been like the
family favor but I went online to look
how to do it I could my mom was like out
like was her grandmother that would make
them like my mom didn't make gnocchi
from scratch so I looked at a couple
videos and that needs more reps was it
good
absolutely was it better than any
gnocchi I've had in LA yeah the
restaurants I go to you yeah I can't
afford the best restaurants but I went
this is great
but it wasn't perfect there wasn't
best gnocchi I had the pizzas I put up
against anybody I used three different
kinds of flour I used four different
kinds of cheese two different kinds of
tomatoes and in the fall I went to the
best pizzeria in the country arguably is
this place called the fara pizza in
Brooklyn Midwood Brooklyn I think
fantastic the nicest people in the world
and the best pizza I've ever had outside
of Naples okay the best and I saw their
techniques and they put the fresh basil
on the pie after it comes out of the
oven and then they give it a little shot
of Port Tana extra virgin olive oil to
bring all the flavors together I did
that little pecorino romano on top when
it came out of the oven and everything
just comes together it's it's amazing so
good you make the sauce from scratch yep
I use DiNapoli tomatoes which are our
san marzano style grown here in
California which I saw in a YouTube
video this guy from Italy has a pizza
shop and he says that's what he uses and
then I also use muti tomatoes that they
use at the forest so I brought I'm
always experimenting it's always a work
in progress it's like your stand-up set
you're like this works but how can I
make it better that's what I've been
doing with the pizza how you adjusted to
life without stand-up better than I
thought to be honest with you I am um I
don't miss the travel I do not miss
being on a plane
I do not miss living out of a suitcase I
miss the store I miss see my friends
that's why I was so happy to just come
down here and hang out with you guys
tonight I miss people and I do miss that
connection when you're on stage where
you just want it when it's working and
you know you're sharing that moment with
the audience and there's like joy in the
air I miss that it's April 14th I have
not been on stage March 2nd Wow the rust
syndrome gives me anxiety to think about
an addict but I know I'm gonna have
plenty to say the first one this spot
exactly and you know what I think's
gonna be rage magnitude and I'm just
gonna be funny just from the ass and
that audience has got to be that
audience is gonna be like this they're
not gonna have a chip on their shoulders
oh no they're gonna be the best audience
there oh I'm looking forward and he said
I'm looking forward that was total hello
Lawrence Sunday I'm so looking forward
to starting from scratch mm-hmm I even
been called back to the videos I watched
in the beginning to get my mind where it
was then when I was watching those early
guys I watched some from DICE last night
that's pretty guy got nice and high me
and Lee drank the magic potion I would
buy his houses
I went by urban trees and a call that
then they would get ready to lock up
they're like man I said just gonna get
three bottles of the [ __ ] juice sadly
away from me on Laurel Canyon I brought
him a bottle we [ __ ] drank it
well I went home and just watch the but
I watched just for the women Dice Clay
has a thing
oh yeah the HBO special for ladies only
you're some [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ] hilarious you know I'm so happy
I got that time to hang around what if
that was as as broke as I was mm-hmm as
coked up as I was as desperate as I was
me you Bobby Lee and Jim Norton in Vegas
we walked into that room and it was all
that food aah
we just looked at each other holy [ __ ]
yeah we were starved we didn't even like
nobody said take your time they put the
planet down we started ripping the
[ __ ] things and then we went for
breakfast a late breakfast and he kept
sending the eggs back stuff like that
would make me so embarrassed you know
the other reason why I would have you
believe it this gives you a lot of time
to think
yep and you think of good things yes and
you also things that they come bad
things say you did or mistake say you
made yeah all this and it's depending on
how many edibles I eat I react through
that yeah sometimes it takes me really
sad sometimes I go I can't believe that
I should call these people right now and
apologize it to one morning and it's uh
yeah I guess who came into my thoughts
and I almost called you
just too late to call you it's never too
late to call me call me back James
arrest us I thought about what was that
James real bit James Price jr. James
price what did he get here
I like 2001 and where we come from uh
New Hampshire and he came right here he
got a job at the lot stall at The Comedy
Store right no he came and he was just
hanging out and he was the open mic or
nobody would talk to but me and nice kid
it'll be giving everybody very nice and
the reason he got his job there is there
was a Eddie Griffin was on stage I was
working the o.r front door and Eddie
Griffin was getting into it with an
audience member
like a drunk redneck dude and then there
came a point where the guy had enough
and this dude stands up and he's like
six foot six and he charges the stage
and I'm like well oh my god but it was
those years where you just I don't know
I just jumped on the guy and I kicked
them and I'm trying to wrestle this guy
to the ground now all the tables are
coming and I'm like I'm in trouble it's
this guy's friends then comics are
jumping in and there's a melee and then
I feel this force of nature and I go I
can handle this guy but whatever this is
I'm done and it was fat James and I just
hear I got your back brother I got your
back brother
yeah he had such a big heart yeah none
of the other door guys jumped in I think
it was maybe Bret Ernst or somebody like
that that jumped in me and then when fat
James used all his weight and got the
guy out help me get the guy out I I just
walked him into the back and I said Dean
you're gonna give this guy a job he
deserves it
and then he became my roommate like a
couple months after that what I'm saying
this from the highest this I love us
yeah I love Hustle I love people foot to
meet everything it just makes my dick
hard you give them a nickel they come
back with $10 yep you do that
I don't think there was a strong hustler
that I met now I been me and fat Jase
the truth you know he tried to get me
though I mean who's getting your dishes
I mean did that move at the spelling bee
akia and the be with with Laurence
Fishburne I know yeah he won on the set
like this what happened between us where
we were good friends mm-hmm I really
like James he would give me money for
coke I don't know I am back hilarious he
was always joke it's such a big heart
such a big heart
yeah he was a funny-looking dude at
auditions that [ __ ] did not [ __ ] around
when he walked into London bro I would
sit there and go oh my god what whatever
he did he was booking it yep there was a
thousand jobs I did with him when that
mafia [ __ ] was big yeah and he would put
his crazy head yeah I think we even
booked the Pennzoil commercial together
Wow that's how we solidified well we put
the guy in the trunk when we opened the
trunk and the guy's looking back at us
and then we slam the trunk and Wow
it was like one day shooting and that's
how I became friends of them and then we
highlight them at the store then The
Longest Yard came along and I still
loved them every hands go they got fired
from the store
something happened yeah I don't remember
what happened so it didn't happen and
then Emmett I was still tight yep and
then when I got a Kia and the B well I
got the longest shot as I was shooting
longest shard he was the one that told
me to go to this place to read for this
girl mm-hmm and it was December it was
getting closed for the holidays mm-hmm
you know you're a little tapped out no
it was all abraeve remember the old al
caputo on La Cienega yes the old how
cool called the synagogue was up the
corner
come on buddy how many more than I
parked in La Cienega Acapulco parking
lot and I walked to the audition and on
the way back I saw that James is like I
already set this audition up you
got this Wow so he goes I'll wait for
you out here let me know how you did you
got to be like three guys don't worry
about how way for you cuz across the
street was the Chinese place the really
good Chinese place would be those pizzas
that yep it was all in that area the
reais took me to that Chinese party
those wasn't there but that place that
Chinese place I had the best chicken
wings except the Jennifer Aniston place
no no in fishes almost Cienega yeah like
two blocks out with Santa Monica vetoes
yeah same table same parking for Chinese
restaurant that was at the same people
they had wings crawl with way nice floor
per order we would just go in there all
the six orders for lunch honesty wins
big thick pieces of garlic on it anyway
so I go to this a Kia in the B it's a
Laurence Fishburne and the chick who
played I think she's in it the chick who
plays knows love got to do with it they
would look up like a schoolteacher or
something as soon as I walked in I know
I wasn't right for the part
yeah it was like the Sun was 16 mm-hmm
I got a couple checks left from the
store maybe I could sell my make us
elevate wall make Christmas happen I go
to a key in the B I eat a bag of dog
[ __ ] and it's one of those places where
they have five different studios yep
auditioning and there's a walk bar by I
look like I said Mars bar Mars bar and
it said international shooting three
days flat fee its money so I didn't say
nothing they had little do me I can't do
international mmm I can't
I'm sorry okay it was non-union that's
it was so what did the bathroom but when
I came out of the bathroom the dude was
like this Steve Simone come on I think I
go Steve so long he looks over I'm
ENGLISH excuse me can I talk to you for
a second he goes are doing a commercial
here
I'm looking for mobsters just like you
get out of here I swear to god honey
goes it's two days to shoot $3,000 cash
and I hope toggle I go what do you talk
about he doesn't want to stay open
Patsy me
Lancaster mm-hmm and then we're gonna
wake up in the morning and drive 20
miles out into this desert and shoot
this Mars bar commercial so I go how
many mobsters do you need
and he goes three of them I go how many
do you got he goes wanna I'm gonna stay
right there and I went out I got fat
James Wow how about being it he goes
going to read the lines we went in
together Mars bar we both got I get him
three thousand one thousand and the
other guy we we had to go to a hotel
I had to get called the whole frame I
had a good time with James these two
days I really got the it's like I got to
know the hairdo or the fact this Frank
and the cheese smell around his neck
because every once a while he get that
Bo to him I will look that I really like
this heart and I really liked what he
was doing as a comic he was doing
something that nobody else is doing if
he didn't get the job he was gonna make
sure you got the job
yes he was very loyal I learned that
from you know that's what that would
people do that without you saying boom
they're an ally they had it Barry why
didn't get this but cut down this and
the tape yeah well how are they gonna
know who told tell them Steve Simone say
yeah but I haven't talked to Stephen two
years who cares all right so take the
chance what do you give a [ __ ] right
that's where the school of thought he
came from yeah so he was like me so we
stayed friends yeah after that come
after that thing we did a commercial
together and then we did that thing
together we were tired I'd see him at
the store and the whole thing I think
they did The Longest Yard
he kept plugging he will living with him
yeah you know we were doing all these
other things
oh maybe we book it was after analyze
that
spider-man - yep and now I was about to
do the Longest Yard The Longest Yard was
in May but that summer because I was
always very good in getting jobs mm-hmm
in December that's a miracle I tell
people don't see if every fall these
little [ __ ] are they crying I really
want a gold yeah so I've shot and I
thought what time I shot a little promo
commercial on Christmas Eve
Wow it shot through six and more than
2:00 in the afternoon they gave me bonus
money and they gave me cash and they fed
me and they gave me another fell
sweatshirt yeah people go all out you
know and we're going in for a [ __ ]
compiled audition one day December 21
some of the best auditioning you'll do
is in December yeah and I remember that
he called me up on that he goes Joey I
got the role for you I talked to the guy
already to chip they were you I love
Jamie tell I love James there's certain
people I don't give a [ __ ] what you feel
like about yeah they did something to me
at one time that was more valuable than
you've ever done yep
and I know for a fact by him doing that
he's got my back so whatever you have to
say around me and you could say it yeah
I'm not communist Cuba right just don't
say it around me cuz you're wrong
yeah I had his back like that I think
somebody started with him at the economy
so it was somebody I had beef over over
fat James I said not on my watch good
for you I find that you bestest that
James there's gonna be a [ __ ] problem
and this is I'm doing coke I'm not a
nice person you know I'm dying to smack
somebody at the spool and one day he
gets me a job the following Christmas I
get a call from him and he's gonna say I
got your job it's in [ __ ] Jamaica Wow
go go to Jamaica it was called hanging
in heat oh I remember when he left for
that well the worst movies of all time
that's the only problem with these best
that made for you to be a silent mute
like if you talk you're gonna [ __ ] die
it there she might you feel like Jesus
before he got stabbed
there's no [ __ ] liquid in your mouth
when you talk with these mess it takes
all the [ __ ] blew it out so he gets me
the audition
we drive together I pick him up cuz even
have a car right he did but maybe it was
in the shop it went down for a while on
his dad had a sin it was a couple
thousand dollars I'm remember so I took
him to the audition and called the city
there was a fat little Italian lady me
and him went in together and they told
this right out you go wow we love you
you leave for Jamaica December 2nd and
you come back Christmas Eve in the
morning and I go all when do we get paid
good we ain't get paid ten days later
and gotta give us something plus per
diem this is no more you'll be hooked up
that Friday I was supposed to leave that
Saturday sure enough all that Monday at
Friday said we're gonna send you the
script in the 70 script I'd done analyze
that you done real I've done a couple
movies they know for a fact that every
day you got a [ __ ] overnight package
in the mail even if it's got no wife
even if it doesn't have anything to do
with you yeah they still send you [ __ ]
so I didn't get nothing I got on the
plane with two tickets that were born
with miles like the first leg was with
miles in the second leg was so every
time I did something I didn't like it
yeah it was one of those planes and
lands at 9:15 at night but it doesn't
take off until 6:00 the next no so now
I'm at the airport all night rolling
joints smoke a little weed I had no
money I was smoking cigarettes at the
time I was in horrible shape yeah and I
take this plane in Jamaica I get there
they pick us up at the airport they take
it to the hotel for a storm the hotel is
a nudist hotel everything around it was
ugly the chickens I have HIV yeah
everything's just bad sign after bad bad
sign I get for the hotel I call you one
of the act
this cosine is all an ass like cosine in
they give me a hotel room and they go
you sharing her own they go Aaron I'm
sag
oh [ __ ] everyone like to call this a
crap they're like whoa for this job you
still have to sacrifice like okay I'll
sacrifice
I had the bellboy already mm-hmm I'm the
Wednesday of the week program so I said
where's the I probably had 60 bucks on
me baby
and a beautiful Bucky's I go way stupid
deal because it was only like 12 days
but damn I'm looking at a hundred a day
at 1,200 bucks
that helps don't know especially I hope
thinks it out that the movie was paying
much they're like scale day is so so
second question I asked so already
number one mistake was the script
number two was sharing the rule flying
on miles and number three was we don't
have to deal I go what are you talking
about saying I think oh no no we have
four dimm but we couldn't bring the
money down from New York
we just gonna send you a check at the
end that day I took the key I went into
my room I took my own cash the bellman
shows up ten minutes later he goes in
his pocket he just went to a tree him
took a bun off the tree it was amazing
he goes ha you don't have the 16 just
give me 40 then so I at least have a
little piece of weed I [ __ ] rolled
that I smoked it the [ __ ] guy went
downstairs and talk ratted on me cuz I
smoke pot on the balcony so one up to
the producers on my gate man this ain't
gonna work for uncle Joey I got Mike
Marino and I got my man Frank you don't
want what's his name for a chance then I
go Frank James I got a problem
this is not the way he's supposed to get
treated if you want to get treated like
this but if not we gotta get the data
but we can't share a room with a met mmm
you know he fell in love with the black
girl oh yeah there was like some
playmate on there there's a playmate
that was the Sherman Hemsley yep so the
first night I'm already seeing
chubbie playing with the flak there on
the factor or just playing yeah so right
away when I went to him his mind wasn't
into me right he's thinking about her
well then go to talk to you if you're an
improv guy or you're a guy that's not
from the commies told I don't know you I
understand I understand
Oh what clown these four guys and I've
gotten you jobs and you got me jobs you
gotta stand on the line with me go ain't
bro Joey might be a junkie whatever the
[ __ ] he says but he's right yeah he
needs up a DM every day that's an every
movement yeah and they were like well
this ain't gonna be like every movie so
I said well then I gotta go and they
said are you quitting or I said well
think about it yeah you're not paying
for damn you got me another room with a
guy you didn't give me the script the
script ain't get here till next week
you've got us here for three days and
they're like you don't need money
everything is exclusive you should have
seen how bad the food everything was bad
like I couldn't eat anything anything
everything was horrible
I read the chicken looked bad the eggs
tasted weird and I was thinking listen a
lot of I'm off the island this afternoon
arrange a plan they called my agent my
agent called me back man at the time I
said does I'm not doing if there's no
Padilla yeah he goes we'll want to pay
for a plane ticket for you I just want
to get off the phone we had called sag
his sag was like give us the producer
them I said better yeah he's 10 feet
from me I walked up to him I game the
phone I said sag wants to talk I can't
[ __ ] believe you bought [ __ ]
sagging to this and all this [ __ ] and I
go you're not paying us you know you got
a pass so what do you want to do there's
a two o'clock flight and like to be on
his fat James and Mike Marino with me
mm-hmm
and also they like to be on it the guy
goes well you can leave that and I
thought right that James getting you
[ __ ] in fact James looked at me and
turns back
ah and then Mike Murray they'll turn
this back I was like I know what time it
is here this doesn't look like it's
gonna work out well for uncle Joey I got
my [ __ ] uh I got on my plane and I
came home I saw my buddy picked me up in
Miami I spent the night with him then I
came back
that's been he showed up you know for
Christmas he came back I think I saw him
at the store like the 27 mm-hmm I just
never could talk to him hmm
I just got my feelings hurt that much if
it was anybody else for many of the
place so when I got my feelings hurt but
you had to battle souls with me every
night I got your back at that place you
got my back at that spot I wasn't as bad
as at Marino as I was infatuated right
Marino was just Marino he had nothing
he's just a nice guy right inside James
met more than this yeah it was like your
brother find James like my little
brother
I had mind him I knew he was all in I
know I could call give me a director
give me a direct Spielberg yeah I could
call still burn and send them fat chance
they'd be in love with him
yeah that James had that thing yeah
hello how he did it
dad James would go on the set and his
[ __ ] energy fat where the [ __ ] a
little pompadour pompadour he had a pump
the pinky ring or the pinkie ring it was
just awesome to see and somebody his
size his weight his dimensions going to
a room why he was [ __ ] Richard Gere
ah such confidence such confidence did
you ever hear him sing he could really
sing sing he could really sing [ __ ]
could say I did see him a single
somewhere I can't remember of all the
places no it's vague to me what year
that he died I don't know I'm gonna
guess o8 so he's been done for 12 years
like Marilyn I want to guess uh what was
probably two three years after Marilyn
so maybe 11
I don't know they all blend together I
was living it was 11 it was 2011 not I
think that but he just got sick um he
got sick they didn't know what it was
and then they diagnosed cancer and then
it turned out that it was a rare bone
cancer that he had for a while that
nobody knew I called him at dinner I
went to visit him we spoke at the end
here in the hospital yeah we spoke we
made our peace they told him I loved up
but he apologized to me anyway he was
pissed too he goes I [ __ ] did that
the chick didn't suck my dick and then I
let the 3 grand she was supposed to take
me to he was oh yeah I'm saying he was
gonna go to the Playboy Mansion and then
she stood him up for the Playboy Mansion
so he was I learned a big lesson - yeah
I said we did I go hopefully when you
get out of there wires from coffee and
stuff he never got I think we said
flowers or something we were really you
know whatever but it was tough I feel
for him now and I feel that I hate when
people don't talk about people in bed
dead
mm-hmm like some people and just forgot
and it bothers me like if you and I had
a good mutual friend that died every
time I'd see you
we'd go can you imagine if that James is
here we didn't want to go to Wayne as a
whole
yeah well [ __ ] McDonald's or
something you know yeah and that's a
burns me out but he will bow and it's
like Marilyn's forgotten that was never
been forgotten my vibe most of the
people who have died in my life I've
never really forgotten every day Mondays
when I light my candles I wanna Campbell
for him you know and I think about him
but just give him the phone ever since I
watched the movie Coco you see Coco mom
it's great it's about people die that if
you don't give them light then they
disappear mmm so you have to put you
their picture up you have bad wake up
what they call it there's a family altar
mmm they call I can all to feed a family
for you to give them light so I don't
have no pictures of fat James
but I just said a little prayer from the
I pray for him all the time but I
thought about you and it's a really
weird thing about growing up because I
have family members pass away my
grandparents and all that but wouldn't
friends start passing it's very
different
it takes you took it out of me yeah
that's tough I mean you know I don't
really especially now but I hate
knowledge Brody's year anniversary
you know I acknowledge that I miss him
but I've never gotten doleful I haven't
processed it yet now they say we're
having process Ralphie may is not but in
time you know the idea was stretch it
and I'm like [ __ ] at least Brody's God
is I've put up with this because he
couldn't deal with not going stand up
now I Brody with a bid on the corner of
world playing drums with the megaphone
the crowd were called and [ __ ] like this
would have just not work nobody would
have had to move them with Brody and
really watch him yeah I think it'd be
funny drumming on periscope all day all
day yeah what are you playing Steve well
what are you looking at right now long
range you have to have three plans right
now short medium and long what do you
think short term is just to keep my
sanity number one and stay in a state of
gratitude I'm praying more than ever and
that gives me a tremendous sense of
peace and I feel good be honest and I'm
grateful for that that I feel good so
that's a short term just keep on saying
my rosary keep on reaching out to people
keep on praying every day then I'm going
to see what they tell us how much longer
this is because my parents are older and
I haven't gone longer than six weeks
without checking in on them so what I
may do is jump on a plane and then
isolate myself if I could get enough
masks and hand sanitizer and everything
or get a tests if they have the Tesco
and and I can make sure I don't have it
I'm gonna go take care take care of my
parents that's the short-term plan or
hopefully they'll open up the world
before that
then a long-term plan is I don't know I
don't know what's after that I don't
know what stand-up comedy's gonna be I
was pitching TV shows I got I'm working
on a movie who knows but I don't know I
have a lot of projects that are keeping
me busy but if things get shut down I'm
like what am I even doing in LA if you
want to know the truth I'm like what do
I want out of life I want to be around
my family I want to be around my friends
and this has put everything in the
perspective of what the podcast started
you said something very interesting that
this is like an earthquake in LA
like at the Northridge and if you look
up how many people left average once you
experience the earthquake you spoke
twice like is this for me
yep I just got a [ __ ] pay cut my kids
are at school all [ __ ] year how much
longer do I want to do this [ __ ] walk so
what the problem is I don't think it's
just gonna happen that way yeah cases in
New York I think it's gonna be a mass
exodus from New York a mass exodus from
my legs they're such expensive cities to
live who's gonna be able to afford to
stay where everything goes in cycles
like yeah at first the country was a
bunch of farmers yeah and they moved to
the cities and that's where the jobs
were yeah I think this is showing us I
think a lot of companies are gonna look
at and be like wait we could have an
office space half the size yeah
and people don't work from home and yeah
but I can live in Florida or yeah Kansas
and pay a third of the rent
absolutely it's uh I think we're gonna
spread out like that something that you
Steve you've taught me that I'm not good
at still is being grateful when things
are bad yeah and there's a lot of this
that I once the sickness is gone I think
it's gonna be a better world
so do I everybody I think it's I think
this was God telling us go to your room
and think about what you've done that's
really how I feel I know I'm gonna get
criticism for that but I think
ultimately if we take the time to
reflect about our lives
we're gonna come out better people we're
gonna do if we're gonna treat each other
better so every day you're gonna come
stronger purse I think so that's it I'm
excited for that I'm legitimately
excited because we're gonna have our
challenges as Americans coming out of
this how we're gonna repair this economy
but I'm so confident in American people
I'm so confident the guys that grow up
the way we did with family with
neighbors with community and we started
to lose our soul let's be honest
everybody wanted to drive BMWs and have
expensive clothes and expensive houses
instead of Sunday dinners you normally
people I never saw a kid once in Los
Angeles in 20 years learn how to ride a
bike you told me a story today two weeks
ago I saw three kids learnt two kids
learning how to ride a bike another
buddy of mine told me that he was riding
teaching his daughter how to ride a bike
we're spending more time together we're
celebrating the little things together
more families are hanging i watch movies
every night and giggle she was in the
shower at 6:30 now we skipped World News
Tonight yeah don't need I don't need to
watch the 5:30 nothing we [ __ ] six
o'clock weed she goes in the bathroom
now she comes out they make popcorn I
[ __ ] hate popcorn really I said I
don't like the smell of it on the other
couch after 10 you don't need to eat
popcorn at the movie you made your point
that's hysterical yeah after 10 you
don't need to eat popcorn you're too big
to be palpable unless you're gonna we'll
have you have frittata that was a cleft
lip then you need to [ __ ] had a pop
all until then maybe the hole then we
watch you know trolls but how great is
that that that family time this is what
this country was about listen I agree I
finished the words up one book now I'm
gonna start a jimmy page book okay but
there's a book in there too I saw that I
really really really want to get in
there
[ __ ] now was the transfer as we got put
what the book was about what was really
important we're talking about what's
really important what you're doing with
your family now and this is what America
was it's what you were saying this is
what America what you know like reading
again yeah and all that stuff the books
but one of the books that I I forget now
so I'm sorry
oh the photos huh it's ten o'clock at
night the edibles are kicking but I like
the reading again I enjoy talking to my
wife again the first two weeks is a
little brutal yeah being locked in with
some money we figured out on boundaries
we figured out ride we figured out
workouts you know and I come prepared to
do another four or six weeks of this
ain't all gonna be better mentally yeah
clearly I'm gonna let all the alright
cuz a book and my thing that's called
ladies and gentlemen Lonnie Bruce
okay and I'm gonna read it again and I'm
gonna read it again because that's the
book that confirmed that I want to be a
stand-up comic and it wasn't because it
was because of what I read that book and
I think we're gonna go back to it now
we're comics are going to start hanging
out with strip clubs and doing comedy
the way we used to like that might be an
avenue like bringing comic and the host
tonight a popular comic but it's bill
burr Theo von mhm and he does comedy and
you know when you read Lenny Bruce's
book you think about him going back to
the Chelsea at 4:00 in the morning and
shooting heroin with strippers and jazz
musicians and no worry did they talk
about cars and fancy cars
nothing like that that wasn't what Lenny
Bruce was about you know right Mitch he
sure was kind of the same way nobody
doesn't like a success but there's a
success to a degree that a comic under
that should be a certain way or unless
it becomes a
movie star ie Eddie Murphy yeah
ie Richard Pryor yeah I think that
comedy got ahead of itself I think that
we were doing comedy wrong yeah I think
the agents and everybody use influence
they agreed you know where I came from
you got a guy a job on TV first he did
ten episodes then he went to the store
for a few weeks then when the episode
started airing he went on tour mm-hmm
sorry Tuesday night that show is on you
know he's that Friday and Saturdays at
the Denver Comedy Works or he's at the
Ontario improv and he would do that for
10 or 12 weeks make some money
come home breast and then start up on
the show again yeah we forgot all that
we didn't want our comics to do shows or
anything no more we got a live comedians
have to live see Rob Riggle we never
said a funny thing of his wife
sweetheart of a guy and dak Shepherd
who's never said a funny thing in his
life sweetheart of the guys I don't know
how many failing shows that Shepherd has
been on well Chris D'Elia can't get
arrested you know I'm saying so my point
is I think the agents started depending
more on stand up and now today they're
paying for it
yeah because when the stand of clients
absolutely actually come back they have
nothing to go to I'm a 200 300 400 cc
crowds if you had to prepare these kids
I've been with them my agency for seven
years
mm-hmm every agent is losing money
because they're not either putting
energy or anything into podcast yeah the
thing that's generating comedy as a
whole
Derek Norris and even after this [ __ ]
strike that they cut down their salaries
and percentages and demoting people they
still won't get a podcast
they're not getting paid right now but
there's 30,000 podcasters that are
making a living and not paying
commissions I'm not thinking of paying
Commission yeah because this is
something they had a self or their
agents and agents like ah people have
Commission look if you call your agent
tomorrow hey
I'm starting the podcast of Ryan's sick
that's great
yeah okay I'll call you later they don't
respect it well that's what I think's
one of the exciting things that's one of
the things I'm looking forward to is how
the business is gone going to evolve you
know like this whole podcast thing is
that's what boomed the state that's what
boomed all the ticket sales that's what
that that's what got live comedy going
there's all these people hearing people
on podcasts and stuff like that so to me
it's exciting I don't know what the next
step is going to be but I'm looking
forward to it
I'm very looking forward to putting
together in the world
mm-hmm I'm like a child right now yeah I
think I got the hook and I can run with
it plus I got an hour old material yeah
then nobody's seen on tape yeah I could
still run that in and really get two
hours going once
everything starts again and we get 20
people maybe a few especially 20 people
small yes I look for $3 online that's it
you know and that's it this is not you
know can I got a call while people don't
have to do this just for starters just
lower your ticket price yeah everybody
will have to take a chunk on ticket
prices because I'm not you're not gonna
sell ticket yeah listen ticket prices
for comedy shows was supposed to be
agreeable with a movie ticket yeah so
everybody can it yeah you know when you
went to a movie theater in the old days
it wasn't the same there was a strip
mall there was a comedy store a comedy
club and what's the best comedy club in
the world
but the [ __ ] pop is sold out so what
are you gonna do alright take a whole
note take it to the comedy show drink
her up then go home with suck at wat
after she last for an hour all right you
never say that's the obvious thing but
if I go into a comedy club and I gotta
pay forty one dollars for our tickets
charge to drinks that becomes something
they're too expensive so I hate about
where the business arganda I was looking
at ticket prices and I was like these
people how can they [ __ ] sleep at
night but but that that's just a small
purse our whole culture did that
everybody everybody
everybody every business got too greedy
and now they want to cry that they don't
have money that's not my problem you
would jumping up and down you know all
your [ __ ] the VP's the senior VPS yes
they all paid themselves at homes or
hundreds and millions of dollars all
those homes and get your wife sucking
dick we're all in this together you
[ __ ] employee you know your wife
likes to suck dick and you're on viagra
[ __ ] make the switch somewhere I mean
I don't get all that stuff I'm glad like
I said to you all these businesses are
the [ __ ] with people write them down
yeah
write them down yeah and the first time
you're gonna do business with them you
[ __ ] up yeah if enough people go you
know what I remember what they did
during [ __ ] whatever yeah want to
give my $45 but I paid to go see Maui
crew yep I'm never gonna give them money
again they can keep the 45 [ __ ] that
we're down here and that's why I told
you guys that first Sunday when
everything was falling apart ago do me a
favor guys get your money back for all
these shows tomorrow I wake up the next
day I sold 50 tickets in Austin uh I was
like I just told you to [ __ ] take
away the shows now the show got pushed
till January yeah it's [ __ ] April
[ __ ] April you know I told you if I
can pull your money away take it out of
there you don't want to give your money
to nobody right now your money belongs
to you yeah your money belongs on to you
if I were to board a motley crew ticket
for 350 right now I'll call them every
day I'll be sending them pizza boxes
with nothing in it yeah until I get my
money and grenade twitches and [ __ ] like
that you know I'm getting my [ __ ]
money you know anything good you watch
over this uh I watched the narcos Mexico
I thought that was great second season
the second one the most recent one I
thought that was really good I jumped on
that Tiger King bandwagon when it was
brand new I didn't know what I was
watching I was it's unbelievable it's
again too many crazy reviews yeah now
too many people kind of ruined it to
watch watch an hour at a time it's too
crazy yeah I couldn't believe what I was
watching and that's it honestly I've
been talking it with one of the
blessings that's come out of this is so
many people
reached out to me people that I haven't
talked to in 10 years people I haven't
seen in a couple years ooh - and it's
like all day long it feels like oh this
is what we should be doing all the time
if it's good I'm spending more time with
people over the phone or FaceTime or
zoom or whatever and then I got projects
I have to work on what they told me from
the beginning I said listen guys before
you go into this illusion mind
there's no debtors prison they don't
throw you in jail for debt I owed
hundreds of thousands of dollars of drug
bills and credit cards they're not gonna
throw you in jail all right you might
have disconnect your phone and get a
burner phone or the girl was there for a
few weeks and little by little it just
starts to fall off your credit bureau
yeah little by little if you drop out
you know when I got into college I
didn't get the cover to be a star I got
to tell me to drop out of civilization
interest I had had it I have had it I
didn't know what you know after my
mother's death and the divorce I hadn't
added bureaucracy I lost a kid you know
I found that thing you have to pay for
the Chinese do anything in this life for
naught tiny he end up in prison or your
deals going to get lost you know I found
out so many things so how many for me
was triple runs until I turned 60 man I
could care less you know drive me chicks
do drugs wakeful live like the catcher
from major league right number one they
call him in the beginning and he's got
two Mexican chicken chicken running
through the room yeah that smile that
was what I wanted my life to be you know
I wanted to live like Charles Bronson
I wanted to die alone [ __ ] is my mind
changed nobody wants to die alone you
know all these things that you have that
you wanted to you changed later on you
know uh this experiences made me look at
things a lot different now I love comedy
29 years I've been doing it I don't see
it for me the next five years
I see it as something to do but not
something up not something I could take
on the road and tour constantly yeah I
don't know I'm gonna try to do I'm gonna
try to add dimension to my arsenal next
couple months let me watch the smoke the
click the clouds part yeah I see how it
shakes out a little my dad would attack
I got an idea I got 30 you're involved
good leave the shop I'm Asian
Lee has to show me he wants to be in bar
because gotta be out of house by 9:00
every day well you took another booster
right before 22 it don't matter
coffee is shallow bang one out of the
shower I think that's important I think
that's a good tip for anybody listening
how to keep your sanity through all this
listen my sanity is very easy yeah I get
up at 7:30 whatever come I get up I have
coffee yeah I talked to my wife for a
couple minutes I do whatever I have to
do on social media yep I brought my
journal and it's where the journal is
finished regardless or what Dominus I
run and take a shower
yeah because that's the most important
thing on this whole thing exactly I make
my car a dog I jump in the shower take a
shower
yep if you wanna jump in the shower put
your coffee on and come on that coffees
on fire I'm not ever gonna be mad that's
what I make sure it's the right temper I
have my rice water you always told me
your schools have that guy's water in
the morning get the system don't you
wake up you have a glass of I turn on
the shower I get my ice water I put the
coffee in the machine I take my shower
come out my coffees waiting for I'm in a
good mood for the rest of the day you
open up your thing you read you're
making notes you see your emails you go
over your schedule for your day you
write your journal ha ha nobody's got
work and nobody's got nowhere to go but
let me tell you something if you sit
there with your [ __ ] pajamas and no
pants on and just sit in front of the TV
you're not gonna do much - it's gonna
affect your brain you're not gonna do
watch the respect it's not gonna work
out all right you're gonna be in a worse
position than you were with this thing
started that's why I advise everybody
you got up in the morning you got an
hour
how are you take that child you comb
your hair like you're going to a meeting
absolutely I don't
you just get in the car take a ride
around the block and go get gas yep
at least you did something make you feel
yourself like you a human exactly I did
something last week but I wouldn't do
for anybody you know last week was no
school yeah so wait a second so we we
don't have a school for two weeks
and then you're gonna take a spring
break and really [ __ ] me up in the
middle of this oh you didn't [ __ ] me up
you [ __ ] up my little girl's head for
the [ __ ] week and the kid didn't know
what to do
so sadly we did a couple things like
Tiffany are here and we were sitting
there she did something good
oh we were here I'm gonna podcast we
have a podcast a law or four we did a
podcast sit down as she did so well
because this one was about music so she
actually had talked about music and then
bring the piano in from the computer but
it tells you what the hit and we say
Yankee do it okay through town Hey she's
like that stop with you know no matter
what these things as always a hey so she
did a great job and I'm sitting here
looking around I go what can I do to put
normality back into her life
yes and I did something I don't wish on
nobody I said just wanna go take a look
I'm gonna go to Burbank go to
chick-fil-a they got a chick-fil-a to go
mm-hmm you know put it in the back seat
wipe it down
I did something better I took a right to
make know she was so [ __ ] happy
because I put more Mellie back into her
life she's in for daddy mommy's gonna
get mad I don't know I'll deal with
mommy
and I put my glove on it was for 62 I
gave the guy a 5 he gave me the change
in the glove I put in a second cup hmm I
took the thing and I put on the [ __ ]
floor that made her weak yeah all we
need is one or two days that we do
something normal I mean I don't want you
to go to the gay club and suck a dick
that's not wrong all right yeah well for
some people I don't want you
go but you still need something to
remind you of the whole to you
absolutely once you start slipping with
showers like people tell me I haven't
shaved in a month yeah I have a woman
told me that they haven't shaving my
legs I had to finally shave my [ __ ]
because it was bothering me you're a
filthy animal
yes worth of it reverse yeah you know I
don't want you to get up a workout you
know why because there's so much stress
on the body right now mmm the psyche
wait you work out you start throwing
punches I could throw five minutes of
punches like nothing now first three
minutes I would did ya thinking Coronas
covered my whole body right I feel spots
I got the measles
that's your mind playing tricks on you
yeah but that's your mind is heavy yeah
your endurance is heavy
everything's heavy it takes me a couple
rounds to fit to the bag to warm on the
count means I gotta look up and breathe
[ __ ] focus at the end of the warm-up
at the end of everything the downward
dogs the stretches you know what I do I
actually meditate that's good and I try
to focus on the sounds of the sky hmm I
do the whole thing I said like a [ __ ]
Hindu wheel and the fingers like this I
thought my eye focus on the third eye
and I know some of you people who listen
to the podcast my last four weeks you
could see that little by little by my
tone I'm accepting what's happening and
this is the biggest thing you could do
right now it's accept what's happening
and prepare have to plan it's a plan a a
plan me yeah you know you said the best
the mass exodus is that would be here in
New York
yep people literally I'm paying 32 for a
one-bedroom yeah I'm doing this and
listen what do I want really want out of
life is a [ __ ] scumbag my friend I
went to college with he'd get me a job
in Ohio yeah in Columbus I get an
apartment for regular New York goodbye
this is exactly where we gotta put all
these people all right where are we
gonna put these New York and California
transplants
you know people gonna be unhappy with
their local state government nobody
can't make everybody happy all right so
that means people gonna be flip-flopping
do you know I've met two people in two
weeks that are friends of my daughter
from the school yeah they're out of here
at the end of May
Wow what just bought a house online in
Texas
Wow and the other one got laid off the
nurse and she's going right to Jersey
they're going to Palm Springs for a
couple days they're gonna come back pack
up the house and they're not gonna
tolerate this no more because what's the
what 50% of this shit's coming back yeah
and the other hand we don't know so and
you have the same dilemmas in your lives
guys and I'm telling you right now is
your uncle Joey do now let this eat you
up you're gonna lose you're gonna lose
you will lose against this you will lose
this will take ten years off your life
now I getting the Colvin what the
whirring yeah pressure on your heart and
the stress on your heart guys whether
you 22 or 50 to take care of yourself
wear a mask span whole you wanna do
drugs you think I'm gonna be mad at you
my people drinking 60% more people the
weed stores can't keep the weed if
you're in the weed business right and
you the longer this last you're gonna be
a millionaire yeah people are smoking
eight a day okay so much uncertainty I
mean that's why I fee I just started
praying one man I'm not gonna give that
up I pray I'm not giving I have so much
peace right now that it I find the
beauty in my daughter mmm I find the
beauty in my friends I take the bounce
when I talk to my jersey friends yeah
well I see what they're going through
I've already offered them like I've
already sent a couple of them good thing
was just like I told them I can't help
you but I don't want you missing any
meals either
well I my watch right I don't want you
to go to Ruth's Chris right what if I
said you a deuce and you bought eight
dinners with
exactly buy a pork loan buy a [ __ ]
yeah yeah and you're 56 that's filet
mignon you cut that in and make tacos
one night suppose and then make a steak
the next night I mean it's not the way
we used to we're going back first of all
if you're normally not eat what you used
to
I'm not eating by far when I used to not
even by far I'm cooking all the time but
I'm eating once a day what I mean I'm
cooking but I'm eating three times a day
nothing from outside the house now I got
away from the bacon I'm back the whole
meal with cinnamon so good friend a
little bit of honey in the morning for
lunch it's a single thing today I had
halibut oats which is zero
it's delicious with wild rice for lunch
portions my white portions about for
dinner we went all out to celebrate
mercy riding the bicycle we made sloppy
joes with tater tots and guess what oh
it's perfect
still got three points left my protein
shake that's great you that's it
and I burn nine points today that's
great tool for boxing and seven filling
you think about it what a blessed life
that is you're eating better your
exercise more there's more balance to
our lives look this wasn't the way it
was two weeks ago two weeks ago oh my
god March 15 and what's again they
pounds outward yeah I caught myself when
I started to go they're gonna have that
they're gonna cut you out of your
apartment if you don't stop and that's
when I just I what's going alright
instead of not eating for 12 hours a day
I went shoot for minimum 15 and today I
think I went like 20 hours or something
I'm cutting the sugar out too yet the
leaf sugar I do like there's nothing
nothing nothing sugary
sugars boys last three weeks I had
something one night with the girls oh
they brought home my wife only brings
home six powdered Donuts so that's two
little ones a piece which I'm like three
points on Weight Watchers yeah but do me
a favor guys when you wake up in the
morning don't dilly-dally
take the shower yeah it'll make you feel
I bet it'll clear your head for the day
and you don't make you do something you
want to do things that you know when I
go outside the workout I start with a
swinging bat but I take it from there
how do I feel with the swinging bat I
did three minutes let's go hit the bag
oh I feel pretty good let's do some ball
bounces Wow
Oh let's do some more let's do some
technical fitness exercises you know
what let me do a [ __ ] kettlebell
today I did those walks like farmers all
have rhythm
Oh back and forth whoo then I did a
couple squats then I did high pulls with
the kettlebells all sculpted I did one
arm falls the kettlebells then I did
curls I got 215 pound dumbbells that's
the best I got yeah and I just did
Charles to failure you know I got the
bat so I did shoulder presses you know
sitting down stretching pushing this way
instead of up yeah that way and having
you back you know I'm just the writing
the journal is big when I read you know
what the [ __ ] I'm reading yeah it's just
a bunch of thoughts so they come until
my head which shows me I'm not focused
yeah well I think that the things that
are helping me the most right now is my
daughter yeah taking a shower I was
living my life like if I was going to
work and I had a regular day yeah yeah
dog your rough mm-hmm I know you got a
rough life but you gotta get up go jump
in the shower yeah breakfast after that
go for a ride if you decide by the time
you come back a you a tie then go back
to bed
right but sure when he did a little
couple things yeah we made yourself feel
good
yeah well I don't want you to walk into
Starbucks I don't want your wait on line
well not timing this [ __ ] few but I
just want you to take a ride see what
people at doors your people doing no
ship I know how for five minutes and go
look at these people begging for Colvin
I wish I just had a co big gun I'm going
there say open your mouth kneel down let
me just give it to you because you're
gonna get anyway today you can see if in
the middle they had a beat and people
talking what umbrellas like the
umbrellas gonna save you from Cobra
[ __ ] the [ __ ] cold vid and [ __ ] the
[ __ ] wet markets these [ __ ] do
what my man Steve Simone is doing find a
hobby cook yeah you know you even told
me you brought it to some of your
neighbors yep which shows me that he
malian you you're a bad [ __ ]
yeah I wish I would promote you tour
dates at the cruise ship I was on sunk I
saw a picture of it I saw bill while
DiCaprio with the girl waving done and
we got no dates do you peanut we got
nothi podcast and nothing but love we're
gonna keep doing them until they make
this [ __ ] stop doing them but wearing
the mask we got the door open I got the
ocean here this would lease spells
sprays between his toes and everything
is beautiful as long as Lee's good
you're good yeah and the church family
is good at home I'm [ __ ] happy with
you guys we're gonna keep doing this
whatever the [ __ ] we don't give a [ __ ]
we push straight ahead the message has
to get out [ __ ] again as far as
dates I got nothing but I pay what I do
got for you I got a deal of a [ __ ]
lifetime because you guys are the
computer so [ __ ] much today I don't
know if you guys been reading the
reports cameras are out more than
anything and they will get your [ __ ]
because you're over there checking the
1850 balance in Bank of America you got
to get the 22 take it out so you better
come up with another dollar 50 but
that's not my point what you're looking
to do is privacy and security online and
expressvpn is great for doing this but
now that you're stuck at home and you
could also use it to unlock foreign
movies and TV shows that are only
available in other countries binge on
Doctor Who on UK Netflix or if you're
into Japanese Annie may use it to watch
spirited away on Netflix
and it's very easy to use even a dummy
like me could do it just opening up
change your location and that's it
choose from over a hundred different
countries expressvpn works on any
streaming service Netflix Amazon Hulu
BBC YouTube you name it the reason my
wife and I use expressvpn it's that as
fast
there's no buffering there's no lag then
you could stream an HD without any
issues and it works on all your devices
that's the [ __ ] Mac Daddy phone
tablet console small TV expressvpn is
there to make everything a lot better
you can see Japanese shows but most
importantly is protecting your privacy
and security online so right now the
church family can get up to go to
expressvpn dot-com slash Church they get
three months free three months free to
get you started
who else is doing that today's market
nobody your uncle Joey's looking out for
your [ __ ] so do me a favor go to
expressvpn comm slash Church support the
podcast watch what the [ __ ] you want but
most importantly protect yourself and I
also want to thank Express VPN dot-com /
Church and go get you three months
besides that I want to thank Steve
Simone I want to thank the [ __ ]
but I want to thank you [ __ ]
for always having them back and being
here for us we love you and remember
what's the church say we'll use a Lysol
is mace come close to us for six feet
you're losing the [ __ ] eye you
understand me talk something that I'll
never get read again I love you today
see you Sunday morning Monday morning
it's 4:20 I'll see you [ __ ]
nice and airily ready get the party
started all right beside that have a
great weekend stay safe and I love you
guys with all my heart I'm sorry about
what you're going through in this
situations but trust me this too will
pass a man god bless you [ __ ]
Lee check this goddamn
[Music]